Hi, Jared.
Thanks for coming, Jared.
Did see you, or not see you
Jared, but glad to have you here.
Stacy Novak says hello,
Dr. Rosen.
OK, it's--
Ah, hi Stacy, welcome.
It's two o'clock, we'll
give it just another
minute. People are still coming in.
OK, great.
Up to twenty four people.
That's pretty good.
That's not bad.
People tend to drop in and out as well with
these things.
Give it just another
minute and get started.
Yeah. Understandably.
People are starting to, um,
experience soom extreme
Zoom fatigue, so
all these online events, so I wouldn't,
you know, you never know, I figure anybody,
any more than 20 people is a good
turnout. Yeah.
All right, we're almost at 30.
OK, we'll go ahead and get started.
Hello, everyone, thanks for coming.
My name is Stephen Naron.
I'm the director of the Fortunoff Video
Archive for Holocaust testimony and
testimonies. And it's
my pleasure to host this
event marking the 10th anniversary of the
publication of a wonderful book,
The Wonder of Their
Voices, the 1946 Holocaust
Interviews of David Boder, published by
Oxford University Press
in December of 2010.
Today, we're delighted to be joined by the
author, Alan Rosen, who will illuminate us
about the history and
ongoing significance of
David Boder and his interview project, as
well as representatives from the Illinois
Institute of Technology, the institution from
which Boder launched
his interview project in
1946, Adam Strohm and Mindy Pugh.
Adam and Mindy help manage the Boder
collection and its online repository, "Voices
from the Holocaust." And they'll give us some
background about their effort to make the
Boder collection accessible and a current
joint project with the Fortunoff Video Archive
to make the two collections co-searchable.
But before I hand things over to Alan,
he asked me to say a few words about how I
view the relationship between the Fortunoff
and Boder collections, and how these two
very different pioneering projects, separated
by decades, share some common, some
commonalities.
I'll begin with a reading of a memorandum
Boder wrote in May 1945.
It was his preliminary plan for,
for the effort to record DPs in Europe.
Much of it, unsurprisingly, resonates with
the approach taken decades later by the
Fortunoff Archive's predecessor organization
called the Holocaust Survivors Film Project,
or HSFP, which began in 1979.
They're five bullet, six bullet points.
And they go something like this:
"There needs to be the technical know how to
record human speech.
The victims should be recorded in their own
language, in their own words, for
psychological and historical reasons.
The victims' many exotic languages make it
impossible for journalists to do the job
competently.
A psychologist must get the stories of all
the participants.
The recordings can be used for documenting the
war and for educating Americans and Europeans.
And six, time is of the essence since memory
and emotion fades.".
Immediately, it's hard to ignore more than a
few significant similarities between the HSFP
and Boder's memorandum.
Firstly, the importance of the use of
technology to do this work.
Rosen, in his book, writes, this clearly
applies to the Fortunoff Archive that, I
quote, "The history of Holocaust testimonies
has been bound up with technology, with
technological advance and obsolescence,
as a means to document or record testimony,"
end quote.
Yiddishist Max Weinreich called Boder's idea
to record interview, "a happy idea."
This idea was followed decades later by a
group of survivors and allies in New Haven who
once again embraced new technological advances
to continue the work that had come before.
It was another "happy idea" in
the service of documenting an unhappy subject.
Survivors in their own words, this time on
video, recorded in the tenuous after
of the ongoing aftermath of the Holocaust.
Some of the other bullet points in Boder's
memorandum also ring true.
Another one is the desire to tell the story of
the Holocaust with the words of the survivors
themselves, to provide them a space to use
their authentic voice.
There's also a recognition of the necessity of
expertise to do this type of work, both
linguistic expertise and a deep understanding
of the cultural context of the survivor,
something that both Boder and,
as an European emigre, and the survivors
in the New Haven community could provide.
They were themselves no strangers to the
European experience.
There's also a shared understanding of the
inadequacy of a strictly journalistic
approach, the importance of a psychological
framing and a recognition of the role of
trauma, an approach also taken by one
of the Fortunoff Archive's founders, Dori
Laub.
Dori, himself the child survivor from
Czernowitz, did groundbreaking work in trauma
studies, had a psychological practice in New
Haven, and brought his own personal and
professional experiences to the project.
The memorandum, Boder's memorandum, also
stresses the value of these materials for
historical research and other disciplines, not
exclusively historical research,
their potential documentation as well as
education. And finally, there is this
brutal recognition of the teeth of time,
even more acute for the pioneers of the
Fortunoff Video Archives, starting in 1979,
after so many survivors had already died.
Boder himself was a psychologist and, like
Laub, saw himself as, I quote, "offering
a service that others behalf, on the,
working on behalf of the DPs could not
provide.
After all, there were dozens of organizations
geared to alleviating the privations of the
present and assisting with rehabilitation.
But Boder and Laub felt that psychological
tools and approaches needed to be the motor of
these, these efforts.
Moreover, both Boder and Fortunoff's founders
felt that many previous attempts to document,
to represent the Holocaust were inadequate.
In Boder's day, he was reacting in part
to the work of film crews, Soviet,
British, American.
The images that played in movie houses around
the world featured silent footage from the
camps. For instance, Majdanek, liberated
before the end of the war by the Soviets and
filmed by Roman Karmen and others.
Boder saw this cinematic approach as
a failure
to document the European tragedy in its full
form.
Alan quotes in his book, quotes a passage from
Jorge Semprun, his account, the
account of watching newsreels in '45.
And he, Alan says that Semprun's words really
echo Boder's own notebooks.
Semprun wrote, and I quote, "What was really
needed was commentary on the images to
decipher them, to situate them, not only
in historical context, but within the
continuity of emotions.
And in order to remain as close as possible to
the actual experiences, this commentary
would have to be spoken by the survivors
themselves," end quote.
Boder would seek to provide this commentary,
this soundtrack, using his wire recorder.
And if Boder's work was in part counter
cinematic, so was the Fortunoff Video Archive.
It too is established as a means to counter
prevailing representations of the Holocaust
and their failures.
In particular around the time of the founding
of the HSFP, survivors cite
their distaste for the docudrama Holocaust,
released in 1978, as a catalyst
for this new video recording effort to set the
record straight.
Their goal was to let survivors tell their
stories in their own words, like Boder.
And I think Professor Hartman would agree
after all. He called video testimony
a new genre of documentation that was,
and I quote, "cinematic and counter cinematic
at the same time."
That quote's from Hartman's article
"The Cinema Animal" on Spielberg's Schindler's
List if you want to read more.
One important difference between Fortunoff and
Boder was the scope of the interviews.
Boder aimed to produce what he called topical
autobiographies.
He was focused on a topical historical event,
the war and its impact.
His goal was not to record a complete life
story. Fortunoff, by contrast, felt
it was essential to begin with the survivor's
earliest memories, capturing firsthand
accounts of what came before the war.
Fortunoff feels that one cannot grasp the
losses of the war without knowing what came
prior, as well as the events of the postwar
period and the reestablishment of lives in new
homelands.
Nevertheless, Boder's use of the term
autobiography underscores an important kinship
with the survivor that is shared by Boder and
Fortunoff.
There is an emphasis on agency in the term
autobiography. After all, Boder didn't say
he didn't call them topical biographies
drafted by a skilled, skilled biographer on,
on their behalf.
Rather, the idea was to use technological
tools to provide the common man and woman
with a chance to record their own
autobiographical accounts, again in their own
words.
In his notebooks, Boder wrote that when he met
with potential interviewees, they would often
seek to provide him with the most exceptional
and unusual stories.
Boder would protest and tell them that he
wanted, and I quote, "wanted the rank and file
experience, not the usual story--not
the unusual story."
For a Boder, the goal was to produce a broad
record of dissimilar groups of individuals,
a wide ranging mosaic of stories from the
war, a goal the Fortunoff Archive also
shares.
Boder hoped the resulting interviews would
help explain to a naive American public
what the unnamed masses of DPs languishing
in Europe had experienced.
In doing so, he had motives beyond
his own academic interest of studying trauma.
There was hope that these stories could
convince the American public to open their
gates to further immigration.
But beyond his political motivation, there was
also a keen sense of an ethnographic impetus
in Boders work.
This is best demonstrated in Boders's many
recordings of songs sung by DPs.
Capturing these songs, in Boder's opinion, was
the ideal proof of the value of the oral
recording method.
Only audio or video in the case of Fortunoff
can capture songs adequately.
Or, as one commenter on the Boder collection
said, it was a way "to
do justice to the oral dimension of the
victims experience." Once
again, this aspect of oral recording process,
the oral recording process is a common thread
between both the work of Boder and the
Fortunoff Archive.
In a way, they both mirror previous Jewish
ethnographic efforts, like those of Shimansky
and the interwar period, or the historical
commissions.
And Boder's recordings
and Fortunoff testimonies therefore also share
a sort of longer legacy of a seemingly
endless effort by practitioners
of Jewish quote unquote, "salvage
ethnology." Serge
Kaczerginski, one of these salvage
ethnographers who recorded music among DPs
after the war, says it so quote,
"The songs the Jews from ghettos, death camps,
and partisans sang from their sad hearts will
be a great contribution to the history of
Jewish martyrdom and struggle.
The songs present the daily Jewish life
in the ghettos with all its accompanying
phenomena like arrests, death,
Gestapo, Jewish power mongers, internal way
of life, etc.
it's all reflected in precisely
in this bloody folklore."
I will note as an aside, that the video
archive continues to explore the elements
of poetry and song and its testimonies.
And we have an ongoing project, in fact,
that's being led by our musician in residence,
Zisl Slepovitch.
And you can learn more about that project on
our website, songsfromtestimonies.org.
Finally, and this is likely the most obvious
connection between Boder in the Fortunoff
Archive is their position as postwar projects.
They both share the rubric of belated
testimony.
Fortunoff obviously more so than Boder.
Belated testimony is often judged quite
differently in terms of value and accuracy
when compared to wartime testimony.
But even Boder was aware of a lack of
immediacy in his recording project, despite
it already beginning in 1946.
For Boder, in a way he had already started too
late. Months had passed since liberation
and this would indubitably alter the type of
story survivors would tell.
Still, Boder persisted in his effort as he saw
the work as essential.
He recognized the lateness as a fact,
but he didn't feel that the work was
necessarily less important than that of other
groups like Oyneg Shabes, who documented
the Holocaust, slow burn and in media res
in ghettos and camps.
It was just different.
The Fortunoff Archive shares this view,
despite its much more belated belatedness.
And again later did not mean
worse. It just meant different.
More importantly, in Boder's perspective,
from Boder's perspective, the boundaries
between wartime and postwar, between before
and after, are less clear than one would
expect.
And I believe we have Larry Langer on
here with us today.
I believe that Larry Langer and Robert Kraft,
two scholars who spent an extraordinary amount
of time listening to and studying video
testimony, would probably agree with him.
They also found that the core of traumatic
memory persists and that there is often some
sort of bifurcation between deep memory and
common memory, the sense of the survivor
leading two lives, a normal life and a life
back there simultaneously.
And as Rosen puts it eloquently in his book,
the boundary between the past and the present
is porous. And I quote, "Since
survivors in the aftermath of the war
have not yet subjectively experienced
a true after, hence testimony
after the war mirrored testimony during
it." These are just a few of
the most obvious commonalities and breaks that
I see between the Boder and Fortunoff
collections. They truly are like cousins,
divided by time and space, share
many goals and traits.
This is why it's so edifying for us to be able
to provide a venue for revisiting Alan's work
today and to publicly discuss with Mindy
and Adam the ongoing joint effort to
bring Fortunoff, the Fortunoff Archive and the
Boder collections together.
So with that, let's move on to our
main event.
Our first speaker, Alan Rosen.
Alan is an impressive scholar
with over a dozen books and innumerable,
innumerable other publications.
For instance, Alan was the editor
of Literature of the Holocaust and
Elie Wiesel, Jewish, Literary and Moral
Perspectives.
His latest book is The Holocaust's
Jewish Calendars: Keeping Time Sacred,
Making Time Holy, which came out in 2019.
That book was awarded the Yad Vashem
International Book Prize.
He has taught at universities, colleges,
yeshivas, and seminaries in Israel and the
United States and lectures regularly
on literature and testimony at Yad Vashem's
International School for Holocaust Studies.
He's a native of Los Angeles.
He studied under Elie Wiesel in Boston
and now lives in Jerusalem.
We're delighted to have him here.
Alan, you have the floor.
But you'll need to unmute yourself.
Some fifty
years ago,
in a different interview project,
a Mr. Slutsky described
how as a boy, a
teenage boy, he came back
from the ghetto one day,
found that his sister
had been taken in a round up.
Mad with grief, he
ran and,uh,
to the headquarters
of the enemy.
And audaciously,
foolishly, dangerously
demanded that his sister be released.
They laughed at him.
And then the head of the
headquarters came
out with a,
with a mean
approach to, to
Slutsky, said, I'll let
her go if you
grow hair
on your, on the palm of your hand.
Mr. Slutsky then raised up
his palm, which was covered
with hair.
The enemy
commander, furious,
grabbed the girl, threw her back
to the boy and shouted that
hey run out.
They were demons.
Mr. Slutsky, as he recounts this, says
that what had
caused the hair to grow
was an accident that had taken
place.
As a younger boy
and a skin graft
had come from such a hairy part
of his body.
The-- and then with
a, a
witty sense
of fortune,
said that the doctors
told him that this was impossible
that a hairy part
of the body grafted onto the palm
should continue to grow
hair.
But he says that
my hand never
went to medical school,
so it didn't know
that it was supposed to follow
those rules.
In a similar vein, Boder came
early before
he had a chance to
have to weather what were seemingly
the claims that the
survivors spoke in
what is called, been called
an anti-redemptive way.
So as I write at the end of my book,
which I'm beginning with here,
Boder believed in closure and
moreover a closure of a certain kind
at the very end of his compilation
of 16 volumes,
300-- 3,163 pages
entitled Topical Autobiographies.
At the very bottom of the page
he had printed in Hebrew
script the word Hazak,
a flourish that was both surprisingly
conventional and strikingly
innovative.
Boder knew well
what he was doing.
The three cryptic letters at the
end, he wrote to his friends, Frances
and Maggie Kaufman, in 1957,
allowing the German K
to creep into his otherwise admirable
English spelling, are the Hebrew
word Hazah, meaning be strong,
and they are imprinted at the
end of each book
of the Torah.
And I then
perhaps can show here
at the end of this
humesh, where I'm pointing my
finger, doesn't have to be seen
in a very clear
way, but clear enough
to be able to know that at
the end of every sacred Jewish
book that hazak
is written.
Just as it is at the end when we finish
one of the five books of Moses,
the, in the synagogue we call out, "Hazak,
hazak
v'nishazeik." "Be strong.
Be strong and be strengthened."
So that Boder
was here pointing to
the fact that he saw at the
end of his 10
years or so
of doing the interviews,
of processing
the interviews, bringing them out in a
book in 1949,
I Did Not Interview the
Dead.
And then spending
six years on his topical autobiography
that he saw this under the rubric
of Torah.
And the closure that
he brought at the end was
to have it exist as
such, which did not in
any way mean that the
testimony that he
brought with the end was
anything less than devastating
to read and listen to.
But at the same time that it
had a, for
him, sacred dimension.
The second comment
to introduce my remarks is
that I was approached a few days ago
by an author of children's
books, who would
like to render
into a child's book
Boder's interview project.
So he asked me, queried me,
well, what did I think would be the most
important aspect
to bring forth
in such a book?
And I responded, the fact
that someone,
was not so young, fifty
nine years old, would travel
halfway around the world
to listen to people
tell stories
of very difficult times,
that act of listening,
which Boder did again and again
and again, not only in the interview
project itself in Europe,
but as he transcribed
the recordings over the next 10
years.
That he listened again
and again and again.
And that strikes me as
an avenue
to point children to,
who are perhaps
often taught about public
speaking.
But maybe not as much about
public listening.
The third introductory comment
has to do with ten years,
and ten years since my book was published
and in the world in general,
ten years is seen, say, dedicated
to finding time,
we know that it carries perhaps
even deeper meaning within
Jewish tradition, the Ten Commandments,
in the Hasidic tradition
we talk about the ten powers
of the soul that emerge.
And we've heard even in the little bit that
I've said that ten years were
important intervals for David
Boder in his project.
When once he,
once he was able to
go to Europe and
undertake to interview
from that point forward, he spent
virtually the next ten years
nonstop in trying
to find every avenue
to bring forth these
interviews to a public who he
felt were deserving
of not only
the superficial encounters
with the, those
who were murdered or those who had
survived that were in
the motion picture cinemas
at that time, but rather to hear
the stories of each and,
each individual,
different as they were Jew
and non-Jew, child
and elderly, and everyone
in between interviewing
in some nine languages.
So those that ten year period,
he also had
migrated to the United States in
1926, so a twenty
year period that passed
before he went on his
expedition, as he called it, to Europe.
And so in thinking
about ten years, there are many different
meanings that coincide.
And it felt me
that it was worthwhile to take stock of
what had taken place during that
those, those years since the publication
of my book to see
in what way it had
perhaps had some effect.
And that's, I'll comment on
a, on those aspects here
today, tonight
in Jerusalem, it's pushing
9:30 at night in Jerusalem.
So we're, we're sharing
many time zones here.
Thank you all for joining.
And thanks especially to Stephen Naron,
who has convened us
here and done so
much to provide wonderful
programming at the Fortunoff
Archive, succeeding
Joanne Rudof, who herself
had done extraordinary
programming and accomplishments
there.
And we're fortunate
to have them.
And also, I
had suggested that we might bring on board
the representatives of the Illinois Institute
of Technology, whose Voices
of the Holocaust
website, which is currently being
built, we look forward
to its launch, but in the time,
in the approximately
fifteen years
or so of its been
up and running, has
been a, really set the standard
in my mind for all the
interview projects and providing access
direction in depth
that allows someone to work with
listening to the interviews
in both regional language
and in translation, so
we look forward to Adam
and, Adam Strohm's and Mindy Pugh's remarks
that will follow mine.
Thanks again.
First, then
to mention that since the publication
of the book, one of the aspects
that has been surprisingly emphasized
to me has been Boder's work
as an archive unto itself.
And I don't think I
thought of it that way at the
time. But at least
two major conferences, one of
which I gave the keynote address,
Yad Vashem have
invited me to speak about Boder's work
in that way.
And I think what it does
is to provide us with
a sense of the enormous
depth and depth and scope
of Boder's
interviewing that would have it be
its own independent
archive.
And I'll say more about
that at the end when I give a short
list of those
projects that I think could be done
to take Boder's work to
even a further stage and hope that
that will be taken up and
happen in the near future.
Second has been the technological
aspect.
Boder's keen sense
of bringing a wire recorder
to interview, which
was, is so astonishingly
seemingly unduplicated, had
Max Weinreich, as Stephen
Naron had mentioned, speak about his
happy idea and then say
it was, the only thing was that it was
surprising that no one else had done it,
and especially striking since
there was the use of recording
in Europe at the same time
in the DP centers,
but to record exclusively songs
and not interviews.
So that that technological side,
it's been a keen interest,
the University of Luxembourg
and a team of researchers who have
made a model
digital, a lesson of
studying the Holocaust and also studying
the various stages
through Boder's, which Boder's work
went through, in,
in,
in looking at the significance
of what they call source digital
criticism.
I think for all that, that
Boder's
efforts ended up being most
strongly dedicated to print,
which is an irony, of course, because
we celebrate his,
his making the recordings.
But he ended up
to see that the circulating
the print, in both his book
and in the sixteen
volumes of topical autobiographies
which he himself paid to
send to libraries throughout the world,
that that was a way to be able
to bring the
interviews into
circulation and to the notice of a
range of different academics
and nonacademic alike.
With that aspect of print
has been the
publication of Boder's
book in a German translation,
which I was one of the editors with,
of, along with Julia Faisst
and, and Werner Sollors,
which came out, I think around
2013.
And
it's, it
was, its
success, limited though it
was, was very striking.
A review was written in the major
German paper, which caused it, at least
for a short time to be something of a
bestseller.
And more than that was
Boder's, on Boder's
wish list was they have
the book be translated
into German.
So we by doing that fulfill
what was one of Boder's goals.
And he felt that Germany, because
they had been the perpetrators,
were in need above,
perhaps more than anyone, of
reading what these interviewees
had said regarding
their experience.
And so that
that has been a
very,
a very rich dimension.
One of the goals, I think,
would be to bring Boder's
original English edition
into
greater circulation,
whether it's a book to
be published, which
I had already tried on
one level to do, and we
decided not to go ahead with that project
for various good reasons, but
another way would be to put
the book on a website,
and that would allow a far
greater readership
and also availability
to researchers than the limited
availability of the book now
allows. And it's not just
having the
eight interviews, four men,
four women, perfectly balanced
in that respect, as well as many others
to be known in a greater way,
but it is also Boder's
striking, trenchant introduction,
his commentary, short but
very revealing on each interview,
to be able to be
that much better known.
It could be done
with taking the
fine commentary that went into the French
edition that I had the privilege of doing
with my colleague Florent Brayard
and with his historical
commentary then being
translated into English or other languages,
that would help to bring
the historical aspect of Boder's work
to another level.
Boder was not a historian,
but was rather a
psychologist who, as Stephen
had mentioned, was very
dedicated also to ethnography.
So one of the most
central ethnographic
dimensions of his interview work
was to collect songs
and the place of song.
He began
to, at the DP centers,
he tells us
with songs by asking those
who he met with
initially to sing songs that
they knew from the war, from before
the war, and that that would
loosen them up.
And then during the recording sessions,
he was
always attentive to
asking about the songs
and having them sung.
And about midway
through, was so taken
by what he had heard of these songs
that he then
orchestrated separate song
sessions.
It seems that if we're to really
capture the ethnographic
genius of Boder's work,
we need to have those songs
not only available
if they are
in part on a website
for ORT and in a smaller
way on the Holocaust Museum
in Washington's website, but
to bring them together with the
interviews.
Because if they exist
in separate realms, then
we've lost Boder as
the ethnographer and
we've lost the sense that the
testimony that he
sought, listened to,
solicited, also came
in the form of the song, that that
was testimony no less
than the narrative
testimony that he heard.
So that would be a
goal that has not yet been realized,
but we hope that both
IIT and Yale will
strive to do that and hope to confer
further on that side
of Boder's accomplishment.
Boder was through and through
a psychologist.
He went to undertake
these interviews as a professional
psychologist.
In the first fifteen interviews,
he used in the majority
of them, the thematic apperception
test.
And in that way, presented
his credentials as a psychologist.
He eventually
jettisoned that test because it
took up too much time, he had
to hear other
kinds of recounting,
but it revealed him
as the psychologist who is
interested as he formulated
on the impact of catastrophe
on personality
and devising
as a result of that, what he called
the traumatic inventory.
There has been some follow up
to Boder's psychological work,
myself and my colleague, who I think is here
today, Neil Lipsitz, have
recently authored an
article to that effect and I've
written some others, and there,
there have been, there has
been attention paid.
But Boder's, his
actual project seen through
a psychological lens,
whole cloth, I don't think
has been pursued.
Part of that is, of course, because
the archives that would allow that
to be seen in context
are not altogether.
There's one archive in Akron, Ohio,
the American Association
of the History of Psychology, another at UCLA,
some papers in the
horror-- the Holocaust Museum
in Washington, others
in Yad Vashem.
So that Boder's
decision to go
on this
expedition, motored
by his concerns
and psychologist, will
need to be taken even a further
step than the chapter I
gave it in my book.
And I think what it
would bring is a sense
of being able to further
clarify why Boder
saw language in the
evidence of trauma that was
in language, is such a central
concern, so that he
would, he
would only publish
the printed versions
of the interviews with the
broken language, even
in translation, that
he felt had been
the result of the experience
during the war.
That that dimension still
needs to be brought out in
a way, I think, too,
for us to appreciate the
depth of the
scars that were left
during the war and continued on
after.
What has also come is
the popularization
of Boder's work, not only the
project of a child's book,
which is hopefully going
to come, but also in
several radio programs that BBC
and NPR also in a
novel by Elliott Perlman,
published in 2011
called The Street Sweeper,
where as novelists will do,
he took liberties.
And to
make the story a compelling one,
as if it seems to me Boder's
story wasn't compelling
enough in its
facts.
But he had a good deal
of success.
But in a way left a,
a larger swath of the
public with a misrepresentation
of Boder as a loner
who had engineered this project
on his own with the,
with the uncaring
responses of those who would not
support him.
And what I found,
nothing could be further from the
truth. Boder was constantly
supported by friends,
family, colleagues, academics,
the world wide.
He was funded for the ten years
he worked on the project.
The National Institute of Mental Health,
who saw his work, has been,
has been certainly
worth supporting in every respect
and it goes on from
there.
Most recently, as a,
as a very intriguing
offshoot of the popularization,
has been a film
done on Boder's
daughter, Elena Boder,
who was a pediatrician
who made striking breakthroughs
in diagnosing
a very terrible
child's illness, but allowed it
to be treated in a better way
and also in
a pathbreaker pioneering in
dealing with dyslexia.
And this
brings to the fore
Boder's biography, but unfortunately,
the historical backdrop
is misrepresented
facts or wrong.
And what we have
of Boder's life is only
also backdrop.
And we're still waiting, I think,
for the, the kind of
popularization, if it's to come,
that will deal with Boder
as a,
as his life story,
which is transparent virtually in every
respect and extraordinary
in its epic dimensions that it
really deserves.
An aspect
of the project that has been dealt with,
but hopefully will receive
more is the reinterviewing
of Boder interviewees that
was done in the U.S.
at the United States
Holocaust Museum in Washington under
the directorship of Joan Ringelheim, with the
help of Elizabeth Hedlund
from approximately 2002
to mainly,
I think around 2007, just as
I was getting off the
ground and working on the project.
So it was a great help to me.
And these interviews are
wonderfully available on
the museum's
website, 10 of
them, and along with the
transcriptions
in either
English as most of the original
interviewing was done or, in
the case of several Hebrew
interviews, with an English translation.
Just a, a,
an aspect show what is
possible that's brought
to us by way of
Sharon, Sharon
Kangisser Cohen's book Testimony
And Time, which is a,
is a first
book really on the
reinterviewing.
She brings the
interview that David Boder did
with Gert
Silberbard, where
he arrives at
Birkenau.
And Boder says "yes
now, and tell me how, what happened in
the first two hours after the train
had arrived in Auschwitz."
So Gert Silberbard says, "we were all,
we were all unloaded from the car.
And immediately a loud voice called
'women, men, women to the left, men to
the right.' I stood with the men in
the dark. I had, we had arrived
late in the evening and
it was already very dark.
Beginning of March.
It was dark. And I had lost track of
father and mother and son, no member
of my family anymore." Boder:
"So you were saying that immediately,
immediately, you did not see your father
anymore either." Gert
Silberbard: "No, I did not see any
of my family anymore."
That's from his interview of summer
1946 in German.
And interviewed in Australia in
2006, the interviewer
says, "So you arrived in, in,
did you, did you, how did you know you were
in Auschwitz?" Gert
Silberbard, who then has changed
his name to Gerhard Silver: "I, I
found out later.
I didn't know where I was when we,
when we disembarked, but I found
out fairly soon afterwards where I was.
When we arrived, we were asked to leave the
wagons. There was an SS man
on the podium and they said 'women
and children to the left and men to
the right.' And I instinctively
held onto my mother and joined her
and my sister, two women
to the left, where the women and the children
were.
And then, my mother
pushed me to the men.
So I think she really
gave birth to me twice,
once in 1928
and another time in 1943.
My sister and my mother
went straight to the gas chambers."
So this reinterviewing
then allows
Gert Silberbard to not
only render
a chronicle of what happened on
arrival, but to
reinterpret for us his
own sentiments that have come
after some
60 years later
when he looks back
on that,
that event and can see
himself twice-born.
As I move to the conclusion,
a
translation, as we just heard there, from
German to English,
the tension and translation
that I looked at in the section of my
book has been
really secondary,
even though I think Boder
who was primary.
Boder, as I comment,
for his work in Los Angeles
on the transcriptions,
felt that he himself was out
of his league and
hired Bernard Wolf,
Polish Jewish survivor,
to do the translation
from Yiddish, Polish,
German to
I think it was some twenty seven
interviews.
So being able to see
what was involved with that
move to a translation
that had to be done by
a survivor, seen it from
inside and Boder
yielding the floor and our way
of thinking of translation.
There have been a number of books
done on Holocaust
studies in translation, but I
think this is moving
to a dimension of Boder's work
that has been largely
overshadowed by other concerns.
The bringing together
of the Boder archive into
the Fortunoff, merging
them together, it's, I think, pathbreaking.
It realizes what I think Geoffrey Hartman
and Dori Laub would have
celebrated.
Dori Laub, when he was made
aware of the Boder interviews,
was so
overwhelmed by what he talked
about as being the rawness,
and our discussions were one of
the most moving aspects
of the work on the Boder interviews
for me.
So having the Boder recordings find
a second home
in Yale is extraordinary.
So finally, to
the to-dos, besides
those that I mentioned, would be,
perhaps, to follow in
Boder's footsteps, to take the expedition
again and for some enterprising
younger soul, or perhaps
not so younger soul, to go to
each of the centers in
France, Italy, Switzerland,
Germany, which of course, no longer
there.
But the simple retracing
may be able to unleash a sense of perspective
of what Boder was doing
that we still haven't been able
to see.
Axel Doßmann, a German
researcher with great dedication to
Boder's work, has done some of that,
but it still is there to continue.
In addition to bringing out
in available,
into an available venue, Boder's
book, I Did Not Interview the Dead, I
think we need to do that with his
two major articles.
We need to do that with
the, if possible, his
16 volume
topical autobiography.
And in that way
that the Boder library
will be open, the Boder
archive has since been done.
To end, I'll end with
what I've been ending most of my lectures
with on Boder.
Which is a story that tries to bring into
perspective the
more,
more overarching meaning.
And I'll tell it in the shortest way possible.
In about something over 200 years
ago, there was a rabbi,
Shmuel Solomon of Lyady, who was
imprisoned in
St. Petersburg.
During the time, the warden
found out that they had a scholar there
and came to see the rabbi
to ask if he could,
he could ask him a question
about the Bible.
Rabbi said, of course, so
the warden asked, in the Book
of Genesis, we find that after
Adam and Eve ate from the
forbidden fruit, they ran to hide
behind a bush.
And God, the
Book of Genesis tells us, came
into the garden and,
and called out, Ayeka,
where are you?
So the warden asked the rabbi
what kind of, what kind
of proposition is this?
God who's all seen, who's omniscient
can, is calling out, where
are you? You can't see them behind
the bush that they're hiding.
So the rabbi says to the warden, do you
believe that the Bible is an eternal book?
Yes, said the warden, was a religious
Christian. Do you believe that
then it pertains to each and every one of
us? Yes, said the warden.
So the rabbi says, I'll tell you what God
was saying when he called out ayeka,
where are you?
He was saying that Adam and Eve, where
are you, not where are you hiding?
But now that you've
enacted this deed, which
has changed the face of all
the world, where are you in
your course of life?
So as I end
with this story and lecture, I
say, this is
what these interviews are saying to
us.
Ayeka, where are you?
You've heard my interview and for most of them
we know, they never gave consent
that their interview really should be listened
to or read.
We are presuming
that prerogative.
So given that we have taken that course,
where are you?
What does this mean to you that you've heard
what I've told you about my ordeal?
How has your life
been altered forever?
Thanks very much.
Thank you, Alan.
Where-- I noticed that a few people
are putting in questions.
You should feel free to, to
add questions to the Q&A button at the bottom
of your screen or in the chat, and we'll get
to them after our
next two presenters
finish.
We're now joined by
Adam Strohm and
Mindy Pugh, who are both representing
the Paul V.
Galvin Library at the Illinois Institute of
Technology in Chicago, both
of whom have worked closely with making the
Boder collection readily accessible to the
research community.
Adam is the director of University Archives
and Special Collections
at the library at IIT.
And he
received his MSLIS from the University
of-- MLIS from the University of Illinois at
Urbana-Champaign.
Mindy Pugh is the University archivist and the
campus historian at the Paul V.
Galvin Library, previously employed
as an archivist and a public historian at the
Chicago History Museum.
Mindy not only supports research projects
within the archives, but across campus,
teaching history in the humanities department.
And Mindy received a PhD from the University
of Chicago.
So I'm going to hand it over to to you,
Mindy and Adam.
Hi, I think Mindy is going to talk first about
the history of the project.
Mindy, I think you are still, your
camera still muted there.
OK.
Oh, there you are.
Good. Thank you.
OK, I'll go on.
OK, thank you, Stephen.
Thank you, Alan,
for your, your great, great work
on this. What I'm going to do is,
is speak about IIT's relationship
with Dr. Boder and his work
and put that in context.
I'm very much a historian.
I do things very chronologically, which I
think is, you know, kind of a good foundation
and reference point for people moving forward.
To say very, very briefly, Dr.
Boder arrived at Lewis Institute, which
is one of the two predecessor schools of IIT
in 1927
and remained at Lewis until
it merged with another school,
predecessor school to create IIT in 1940.
And then he was at IIT until 1952.
I won't rehearse the
chronology of the project.
I think that's pretty much preknowledge
for most of you who are attending this
conference.
He retired from IIT in 1952,
not in a great relational
posture with the, with IIT.
I've seen documentation to indicate that
he left rather dissatisfied,
perhaps a 10 month, $10.00 a month pension
was part of it.
But after he left IIT in 1952,
his ties were pretty much
all in the past at that point.
He went on to have more productive
relationships obviously after that,
in 1952 onward with UCLA,
his continuing relationship with the
Psychology Museum in Akron,
which dated back to the 1930s,
that continued.
And of course, then he developed ties in
Israel as well.
And those were
his moving forward, points of reference.
That said IIT's legacy is
still very important.
But for us, it's been a process
of rediscovery.
It's not been a continuous connection with
him either personally or in
terms of his work since 1952.
We've had to also rediscover
Dr. Boder in what he meant and what he means
to this day.
IIT went through a tough financial
time in the 1970s and 1980s,
to the point after the economic downturn of
the early 1990s, there was quite
an open question as to whether the, whether
IIT would even continue as an institution
or whether it should move to, say, DuPage
County.
Fortunately, in the mid 1990s,
a number of prominent
individuals, Bob Galvin of Motorola
and Bob Pritzker, stepped forward
to offer matching funds.
And IIT was basically reborn
in the mid 1990s.
As part of that rebirth, in that recommitment
to its south side campus at 35th and
State and its rediscovery
of its heritage so that it could truly
anchor and be reborn in its old
location, it started to,
as a corporation, take a much more serious
look at history and the institutional history.
The university archives, which had gone into a
period of abeyance during that latter
part of the crisis years was reborn
in 1998, and
Galvin library
entered into a more dynamic period
of trying to promote institutional history
from the late 1990s onward.
I can't speak about IIT without mentioning
two individuals at Galvin Library
in that context in the 1990s for
whom the Boder project owes a great deal.
The first is Christopher Stewart.
Christopher Stewart was hired at Galvin
Library in the mid 1990s to spearhead
moving the card catalog to digital
and also to promote Web developments.
Early efforts to move
into the electronic era.
And very closely associated with him was
Kristen Standaert, who's still there.
Kristen is the associate dean for
administration.
Those two spearheaded a lot of
the forward thinking projects
that would move Galvin Library into the 21st
century.
And
Christopher and Kristen,
at a point in the late 1990s when they are
looking for projects to to
put online and to create
sort of a Web presence for Galvin Library
and for IIT,
tries some sort of preliminary efforts.
But then they were
clued into the existence, or were reminded,
or indeed informed about David Boder
and his legacy by the psychology department,
Dr. Ellen Mitchell,
who is head of the College
of Psychology at IIT in the late 1990s.
She had happened upon Galvin Library's
copy of the Boder transcripts from
the 1950s and they had always
been there.
But she saw it as something of a rediscovery
in terms of alerting her to this
important person in the history of her own
College of Psychology at IIT.
And she, she
very quickly liaisoned with Christopher
Stewart in terms of creating
a Web presence for these rediscovered
transcriptions.
And so this is after
a period of over 40 years
where IIT basically lost sight of David
Boder, that there's a rediscovery
of this legacy, and it's an IIT legacy
in large part.
That this
synergy and rivalry to a certain degree
between the College of Psychology and
Galvin Library emerges,
but it has great product.
In 1998, 1999,
Kristen Standaert and Christopher Stewart
negotiate with Library of Congress
to obtain a
copy set of the Library of Congress's wires
so that IIT could
return to itself
Boder's interviews, audio files.
And they, I believe, put
twelve of those audio interviews
on the initial Voice's site, which I think was
inaugurated in 1999.
And then they put up about 40
to 50 of the transcripts.
Now, this is before OCR character recognition
was very effective.
So Stewart and Standaert involved
a large portion of the staff at Galvin library
in reentering those transcripts
so that they could be put online.
I hear to this day testimony
from various of the staffers there who
survived from that era who said that,
how interesting, but also how traumatizing it
was, to have to enter in
every last word of, from those transcripts.
The upside of that, it was certainly a
community all hands on deck
thing and a real reintroduction
of the Boder legacy into Galvin library
through that that whole process.
Christopher Stewart went on to become library
dean, and I believe it was 2006,
just a few months before I came on board from
the Chicago History Museum, where I had been
for some time.
And I have to,
Christopher was very-- is, he's no longer
at IIT, a very interesting
individual.
Christopher Stewart, and again, you cannot
gainsay his import to all this,
had a high sense of
commitment to truth.
For him, a library is not just a space,
it's not just a kind of a meeting place, it's
not just simply the dissemination of
information. It's a place where
people are invited to, to
look at evidence and to verify truth.
He had very much a sense
that truth is a contested
zone. And of course, we nowadays,
in the era of
Trumpism, we tend to see that now,
we recognize that.
But Christopher has a sort of foreboding of
that.
History didn't end with the fall of the
Berlin Wall in 1989.
We all kind of hoped it would, that
things would usher
in a period of amity between East and West
and that those rivalries would be gone.
But unfortunately, the Yugoslav civil war in
the 1990s, 9/11 in 2001,
and the hard line
Iranian leadership in 2003,
4, 5, under President Ahmadinejad
really revealed that truth was still
going to be contested, that
narratives could still be worked and
shifted.
And Christopher Stewart was very determined
to make sure that people could judge for
themselves.
Read the transcripts, hear all of the audio
interviews, have all of that out there.
And once he became dean in 2006, he,
he moved that project forward from just a
small sampling of materials to as much of
the audio files as he could put online,
and as many of the, and, all of the
transcripts and translation, and in
transcription that he could, could muster.
And so the second iteration of the
site went up in 2009.
And yes, there was something of a real
sort of...again,
as something of a real philosophic commitment
that Christopher Stewart had to that which
was very exciting to work with, in
terms of that.
For me professionally, it was very fulfilling
because I came with a history degree
in European studies, not just U.S.
studies, and to be able to support that
effort.
Again, that notion of contested space
that we we live in, as John
Kennedy said in 1961,
a period of hard and bitter peace.
We still are in a period of hard and bitter
peace, where
we need to stand up against demagogic
populism and we need to really commit
ourselves to robust
platforms where evidence is at
the foundation, so that
at least people of, of, of
good, good, good will and
a commitment to truth as we understand it in
academe could strengthen
themselves and carry forward
Dr. Boder's message, which was,
and still is, his legacy lives,
a commitment to the truth.
Let history and let the world be a judge
of his work and let it be a judge of
what actually did, did occur.
So, I'm going to turn it over
to Adam. But that's, that's my contribution
on that.
Thank you, Mindy.
So I'm going to talk a little bit
about the current state of
the Voices of the Holocaust project.
I will give you a kind of sneak
preview of the new version
of the site that we're working on now and kind
of discuss what we're hoping
this new move can kind
of bring to the material
and people's experiences with it.
Let me just share my screen
here.
OK, so this
is the Voices of the Holocaust
site, as Mindy mentioned, that
was put
up in 2009.
And this was the Voices of the Holocaust
as it existed until very recently.
The site was, of
course, generated a lot of traffic.
We were constantly
chatting with folks about it, interested
Holocaust scholars, high school students,
you name it.
So it was a very popular site and we knew
that. But we also knew that it was beginning,
technology-wise to get a little long in the
tooth.
And the point at which we knew we
needed to make a move was when
Web browsers started disabling Flash
technology by default.
This meant that essentially
to get any of the interviews to play
on a modern Web browser,
you had to know where to go to tell it that
it was OK to use Flash.
So I, I had an email copying,
an email that I copied and pasted, I don't
know how many times explaining to people
how to do this.
And it became clear that this, this just
wasn't tenable.
We also knew that the Text Encoding
Initiative, TEI format that was used to encode
the interview translations and transcripts
wasn't quite, it was, it did
its job really, really well.
But it wasn't as interoperable with
modern Web technologies in terms
of video playback and audio and text
synchronizing.
And we were kind of kicking around some
ideas. We had, a few of my colleagues
were working on some demos
of some things that might work.
And that's when Stephen approached us
about the idea of adding the
Boder interviews into
the Aviary platform so they could sit
alongside the Fortunoff Archive interviews.
And not only
was the idea of bringing these all together
a great idea, but
we realized after a little bit of exploration
that the Aviary platform
could serve as a,
a way to kind of service
the techno--technological underpinning of
the new website.
So this is the interviews as they look in
Aviary.
And I'm kind of playing around within
the Illinois Institute of Technology
collection here, but as Stephen mentioned,
these interviews will come up in a search
right alongside the Fortunoff Archive
interviews. So, you know, there
is a, there's a real
kind of connection being made here that just
wasn't there before, for the Boder interviews.
So if we look for
the aforementioned Mr.
Silberbard, you'll see that.
Maybe, maybe his Fortunoff interview, well, I
should have done this search ahead of time,
but I decided to improvise based on previous
content.
But regardless, you can see here
that interviews are popping up next to each
other. And this is, to my knowledge,
the first time that
the Boder interviews, that kind of a
word by word level have been kind
of taken out of their silo.
So then I'll give you a brief demo
of where we're at now, starting with
the, the apology that this is
visually, this is very bare bones at this
point, this site. We've, most of the work
we've undertaken to this point is of more of
like a technological
and data migration
efforts. We have not done a whole lot in terms
of design.
So take that in mind
as I, as I kind of drive through here.
This site is built in Drupal
using software called Islandora.
These are two platforms that
we were already working with and committed to,
so it became a very natural way to do this.
And we migrated, we tried to migrate
every little bit of data that we had from
the previous site over to this one.
There are a handful of things we're still
working on integrating.
But that meant a lot of,
a lot of remediation that had to happen
by hand, especially because Aviary
wanted data in some ways--formats.
Islandora wanted it in others,
and so a good bit of my time
over the past six to eight months has been
spent kind of going hand by
hand through these interviews at times.
And I will echo what Mindy said about it,
it's been very gratifying and
intellectually stimulating work at times, but
not, not always the easiest
thing to spend, spend my day going
through, especially during a pandemic.
So there were some interesting times this
summer for me.
So I want to just briefly
kind of make a little run through
things here and talk about some
of what this site will provide that the older
site didn't.
So the the search and browse interface
is a bit more,
a bit more in line with what modern
Internet users are going to look for,
including things like faceting.
So I can take the interviews and say,
well, I only want people in their twenties.
And, you know, people
in their twenties that were born in Greece,
and so it's very easy to kind of
narrow in on a particular
interview or a particular set of interviews.
We, of course, have searching by terms.
And so if I'm looking for any of
the interviewees who, say, worked in a factory
or talk about work in factories,
I can then again do this, this same sort
of narrowing down to
find what I'm looking for.
We're working on this knowing that some folks
are going to be coming, just kind of
interested in the idea of this project
and not really looking for anything in
particular. But there will definitely be
scholars who are
looking to find some very specific
things in these interviews.
And we want to try to allow for both.
So within the interviews here, you can
see that it embeds a player window from
Aviary into the site here.
And we have and you'll
see that much of the search that I did there
is represented here.
And I can actually jump directly,
directly to those.
So we're trying to make it as easy as possible
for people to get to what they want to hear.
And then I can immediately
jump to this spot in the audio and I'll just
let this interview play for just a moment.
--the office maybe I wouldn't be alive anymore
because the factory work would be too difficult
for me.
Yes. Did they pay anything for the work?
Nothing.
Well, when you needed some things, soap
or...did you have toothpaste?
Oh. We didn't get anything
from them. Just one little piece of soap
and we had to wash ourselves only with water.
You washed yourself only with water.
And oh yes, we got one piece of
soap, but that wasn't enough for the whole
month.
And how did you handle your laundry?
Or did you wash you clothing?
Everybody knows that in camp wasn't so clean.
So that's an example of how,
how someone looking for a very specific thing
can kind of, hopefully access it as quickly
as possible.
Another really important part of this project
that I think has
something to do with the
kind of the idea that
Stephen was talking about earlier, and Alan
and Mindy have all mentioned this, this idea
of connecting, connecting this work.
And one of the things that is,
has been fairly big in kind of Web projects
of this sort over the past, I don't know,
decade or so is this idea of linked open data
and this idea that
all of these data points within
these interviews are things
that other people in other projects
and other places are also referencing.
And so one thing that we tried really hard
to do is to build on already, I don't know how
many hours of work done kind of laying
that, laying the groundwork for this in the
initial site.
But we tried to as much as we could.
And there are still a handful that I'm playing
with a little bit here, link,
link out records for any camps, people,
or places to online authorities.
And to try to do
things like represent, represent
which camps were subsidiaries of
others, simple things like which
cities are in which country, and you can now
kind of balance between a city, look at every
city mentioned in that country and jump over
to those.
And then we, we also have a way to represent,
you know, here is every interview
that Gross-Rosen is mentioned.
So there is, there is also a
very uninteresting kind of
underpinning to this that my colleague Tim
Flohr is going to work on, that will allow
people to kind of access this data under
the hood, let's say, and, you know
that way, if, you know one
of the big things in, in projects like
this over the past five
to ten years has been people building these
portals that give you kind of access
across a spectrum of institutions
or projects.
And this will also, the work that Tim
is doing is also going to make that possible
for these Boder interviews, that we'll be able
to hand someone a, you know, a
figurative bucket of data and have them
loaded into their system, that
will hopefully allow us to point
people to these interviews and
to have people find them without already
having to know they exist.
Because up until now, a lot, in
a lot of ways you would have to know that the
Boder interviews existed to find them.
And it is our goal to
make that not so necessary.
One other thing I wanted to quickly point out,
you know, the
work that Alan and others have done to
contextualize Boder's work
and to tell his story is,
you know, I will speak for myself, but
I think I can speak for us as an institution.
It's, you know, it's not something that we
would be able to do. And we've, we've tried
to take a just the
facts sort of approach to this
and allow others to kind of expand on
that story where they have the expertise
to do so. But we, we
have been able to include things like
Boder's annotations that were present in his
transcript, as well as for
selected interviews, we have scholarly
annotation and commentary and
we've included that as well.
But for the most part, we have not
done any additional sort of contextualization
outside of the kind of linking to
authorities and that sort of thing.
It's something we're not averse to.
But we did not feel that we were, we were in
in a situation where we can do that now.
In terms of what's left to do on the site,
there's still a little bit of research work I
have to do on town
names and things like that, that people
said and maybe Boder perhaps didn't
transcribe correctly.
And so for decades it's been a little,
a little foggy.
I don't, I don't claim to say that I will
be the one to figure it out, but trying
to do my best.
Obviously, there's some design and aesthetic
work to be done here.
And then a lot of the work under,
kind of beneath the surface of this that's
going to make it really interoperable with
other, other portals,
other projects.
That's work that's ongoing as well.
I wish I could say that we had a great
date set as kind of the relaunch
for the Voices of the Holocaust project.
But to date, we don't.
This, unfortunately, is not anyones
full time project right now.
And as I think anyone, anyone
can attest to over the last six to
eight months, it's been, it's been difficult,
but we're hoping early 2021
the site will be ready to go.
And until then, if you, if
you navigate to voices.iit.edu,
it will, it will bring you to our
collection in the Aviary platform.
So the interviews are still accessible.
All of the annotations and the
metadata for the interviews, the descriptions,
the commentary, it's all there.
But hopefully within the next few months we
will have the site done and be able to present
it in the format that we think makes it most
usable and also,
you know, hopefully most
enlightening to our users.
And I think that's it.
Thanks.
Thanks, Adam, and thanks indeed.
The site looks, that's the first time I've
seen the site with the Aviary embeds,
and it looks very good.
It's very exciting to see that.
OK, we have a few questions
in the Q&A
tab here, so I'm going to just read
them off.
For Alan, this
one's from Shira Schmitt.
Does the religious or non-religious identity
of an interviewer make a difference?
If so, how does it impact on the interview?
Thanks for the question.
Boder was a
traditional Eastern
European Jew, so it was very
important that he could
actively speak
six languages and had
passing knowledge of three others.
He wasn't a,
he wasn't a religious Jew
in the conventional sense.
So when he interviewed
those who were,
which took place the Henonville
interviews and other places,
he tried to cope.
And so
there is a gap, it makes a difference,
but what we
have is his
eliciting a chronicle
and commentary from the interviewers,
religious or not,
not conventionally religious.
And so he,
he did what he could.
I don't want to say more than that generally.
Stay, I'll stay within
the Boder interviews.
OK, another question, this
one from Joanne Rudof.
Why do you think it's desirable
to popularize David Boder's work,
since such popularization has the potential to
be more harmful than helpful?
That's a great question, Joanne.
Thanks.
I think that...popularization
brings a,
brings knowledge and awareness.
And can
already plant the seed of an idea that
someone
conceived of.
Taking such steps
to an expedition to
listen to people that he had no connection
with, so I think that can be very
inspiring for
those in their daily life
as well as for, and
for academics.
So I think Boder's initiative was so
inspired and
resourceful, that
it has the possibility
of bringing that inspiration
more generally.
So that's why I think it's important.
OK.
Another question from Oren Stier,
he is intrigued by the notion of public
listening as something that you, if
he understood correctly, you spoke about
public listening in your presentation,
what might public listening look like in
practice, both academically and more generally
today?
Thanks, Oren, for that
searching question.
So, just
beginning thoughts on that
and that notion, and look forward to
the conversing with you
about it at greater length.
So I think that the focus
is often, as I mentioned on public speaking,
that through one's education, one feels
pressured
to speak well,
express oneself well,
and that takes,
that takes precedence.
And listening can
also bring a very, very
great results, as I think
Boder's interviews
show, as the Fortunoff Archive
display.
So public listening?
I was thinking of in a sense that
he was not speaking
about listening in terms
of a private activity
that one does
on the telephone or with a friend,
but rather in a way, in a classroom,
in a lecture, in
seeking to elicit
information and a chronicle
from those who have gone through difficult
experiences.
So a public,
public listening would have
that kind of grooming
of the skills of listening that would
see them as a
very
important, perhaps even crucial
part of
education and also
ethical life.
That's a great answer.
Thanks, Alan.
And one more question from
Joanne, this one is for Adam.
How can you begin to judge quality of
potentially scholarly annotations?
Is it risky to include these in terms of your
institute having to judge the quality
of the scholarship?
That is a good question, and
it's a point at which
Mindy spoke about Christopher Stewart and
his, his, the
importance that he placed on the truth,
and some of the other folks from
Galvin Library that worked on the project.
Evan English is another, another
former, former Galvin staffer who did a lot of
a lot of work related to this and
every indication that I have
gotten from anyone,
including Mindy is that they did this very
scrupulously, there was a,
there was a committee set up
that was kind of the scholarly
support committee for the project,
and so all of, all of the commentary
and all of that kind
of extra, extra context
that we're bringing in, we're reproducing
what was on the site before.
And I am aware that to some extent
me saying we're taking what was there and
putting it, putting it there again
is a little bit of a cop out.
But as as your question correctly indicates,
I am certainly not in a place
to feel that I can, I can judge this.
And really,
to some extent, we, we kind of hope
that the folks who really,
really know what they're talking about are
going to be using the site, interacting with
the site and offering
suggestions and commentary.
Axel Doßmann, who Alan mentioned earlier,
who indeed is a wonderful
resource pertaining to Boder and all of his
interviews and has done some amazing work,
he and I had some really interesting
conversations about
kind of the data we had and the site we had,
and things that he was doing at his
home institution and ways they were
expounding upon some of what was in the
interviews.
And we we would love to do kind
of a full bore scholarly review
of all of that.
We're, we're not at a place right now where we
could do it, unfortunately.
But, you know, in the future,
perhaps we can.
So really, I'm, I'm standing
on the shoulders of Christopher and Evan and
Mindy and Kristen and people that worked on
this project previously.
And I owe them a debt of gratitude
as well as Stephen, who, again, I
just want to point out, without his kind of
enthusiasm and support, this
whole version of the Voice of the Holocaust
would not be, perhaps not be extant
at all, or at least it wouldn't be what it
was. So I just want to make
sure I say that as well.
Thanks, Adam.
OK, we've definitely
gone a little bit long.
And speaking of public listening,
this was an exercise in public listening.
So I appreciate everyone,
everyone who came and stayed with us to the,
to the end.
If there are any other questions you,
for, for Adam or Mindy, or for Alan that you
didn't feel comfortable addressing.
Now you can always send them to me and I'll
pass them on by email.
But thank you again to Alan,
and to Mindy and to Adam for all of your work.
And congratulations on ten, the ten
year anniversary of
your book, Alan. It's still a wonderful,
wonderful piece of scholarship and
it continues to sort of
impress our work
at the Fortunoff Video Archive
and impact our work.
So I appreciate you being here,
OK?
And with that, we'll bid
everyone adieu.
Thanks for coming.